moi je reste sur mes positions je pense
que c'est pas un métier ce n'est pas un
métier ce que vous faites je pense que
vous avez été utilisé par une plateforme
qui surf sur votre buzz et moi pardon
mais j'en peux plus d'entendre les mots
business chef d'entreprise commerce on
dirait des patrons du CAC 40 pardon mais
vous dites où vont des contenus digitaux
à nos abonnés pardon la chauve-source
que vous vendez c'est votre cul je suis
désolé mais c'est vrai ce n'est pas un
travail ce n'est pas
le jour le jour où c'est de parler
mais arrêtez de faire croire que c'est
un travail ce n'est pas un boulot
du chat de 40 c'est un métier Guillaume
c'est pour alors acteur porno
professionnel c'est un métier je pense
que vendre des contenus j'ai regardé vos
vidéos elle coûte 3 euros je trouve
pardon en fait ça me fait de la peine
pour vous